good morning I'm it's February already
I'm back from my hiatus I was so burned
out doing all those SAT problems but now
I am ready and I will start doing some
physics so we've done a bunch of
projectile motion what happens when you
throw something in the air drop it from
a cliff but now I will introduce you to
is how do you actually effect the
acceleration of an object and to do that
I'm gonna introduce you to Newton's
three laws Newton's three laws and this
is kind of to some degree what we were
doing before was derivative of what I'm
going to do now but this is kind of the
backbone of classical physics so
Newton's three laws and you've probably
heard of these before Newton's three
laws or sometimes a column Newton's laws
of motion or I've actually looked this
up on the web just to make sure to see
if there was any correct way of writing
it but every web site seems to have a
different paraphrase of the laws but
hopefully I can give you an intuitive
sense of what they are so the first law
is an object at rest an object an object
at rest tends to stay at rest stay stay
at rest and an object in motion tends to
stay in motion this is what I learned
when I was a kid now when I look at
Wikipedia and things there are some
paraphrases and we'll go over those
paraphrases because I think they're
instructed stay in motion and you might
say Sal this is obvious why does Newton
get so much credit for stating the
obvious obviously if I look at my sofa
for example it is an object at rest and
if I keep staring at it it tends to stay
at rest
likewise when I look at a car crossing
an intersection that's that's not a red
light that's crossing intersection it's
an object in motion and then I don't
know but ten seconds later it's it's
still staying in motion and of course
it'll you know it'll stay in motion
unless you press the brakes or whatever
so you might say well Sal this is this
is the most obvious thing ever this dish
doesn't even need to be written down but
let's say you were Newton and you came
to me and
some time was in seventeenth-century and
you said Sal have these new laws and the
first is an object at rest tends to stay
at rest and an object in motion tends to
stay in motion as say Newton I can
already disprove your law let's say I
have an apple and I'm holding it up at
let's say my I'm holding it up with my
arm so it's roughly you know my shoulder
level so I'm holding an apple this is an
apple looks like a heart but it's an
apple so I'm holding it with my hand
drawing my hand I don't know if that
makes sense to you but I'm holding it my
hand and what happens when I let go of
that Apple so while I'm holding with my
hand it's a it's an object at rest right
but then when I let go what happens it
falls right falls to the ground
so I'll say Newton I just disproved your
first law because this was an object at
rest and I did nothing to it I just let
go I didn't apply I didn't push it I
didn't pull it I didn't throw it I
didn't do anything and when I let go it
just fell to the ground it started
moving without me doing anything even
though it was an object at rest and then
Newton will say oh well that's because
you know there's this thing called
gravity and it's the force of gravity
and I would say Newton you know you need
to start to learn to not make up things
you know just because your
your-your-your law doesn't make sense
you don't need to make up all artificial
forces in the universe but anyway he he
would end up being right and and the way
to think about this if I did this exact
same experiment while I was in space and
it just let's just say I was going to
say orbit because it would look like
that
but even orbit is kind of a is you're
still kind of falling towards the earth
it's just you're moving well I won't go
into that I'll go into orbit at another
time but let's say we went that we were
just in deep space and me and the Apple
we're just floating around in space and
you know we don't even know maybe we're
stationary it's hard to say we're you
know floating with respect to what and
then if we're in space and I let go of
this Apple what happens to the Apple
nothing it's not going to fall anywhere
it's not going to move and so whenever
you think about Newton's laws and that's
why this is so amazing
he didn't know about space he didn't
he's living in this planet that you know
everything tends to fall and things
start moving for no reason because of
whatever gravity and the wind and
whatever else and and and he actually
there
there could be a place where there's no
forces acting on objects where if I were
to let go of this Apple it would just
stay where it is and similarly the
object in motion tends to stay in motion
and there again I would have told Newton
well you know that doesn't make sense if
I were to if I were to I don't know if I
were to push a if I were to push up well
I don't know if they had bowling balls
back then but if I were to roll a
bowling ball down a Down uh well let's
say up a hill right at some point that
bowling ball is going to slow down right
if I if I rolled it up a hill at some
point it's just going to slow down and
maybe if I got it right it would just
stop at the top if I did it perfectly
right and I can say well this was an
object in motion at some point it stops
or it actually turns back around or even
if I were to roll it this way at some
point it's just going to stop right the
bowling ball is going to stop or another
way I could if I were to push something
as hard as I could maybe it maybe it
travels for a couple of feet but then
it's going to stop and he'll say oh well
you know there are these forces that
you're not realizing there's a force
there's the wind resistant to the
bowling ball example there's the court
there's a force of friction in the
example where I just push something and
I would have said well Newton you're
just making up these these forces again
and this is why this is so non-intuitive
because he he had to essentially realize
that the world with these forces acting
on something when to someone at that
time you wouldn't have realized that and
you wouldn't have been able to even
conceive that there's a place called you
know space for example where these
things wouldn't happen if I if I push
something in space it will keep going it
will it would be an object in motion and
it will keep that velocity until some
other force acts on it so it's so it
wasn't that intuitive and so a more
modern a more modern way to write this
is to say that there is a frame of
reference there exists a frame of
reference and I'll explain what a frame
of reference is but there exists a frame
of reference where this is true that
that could be the new way of saying
Newton's first law of motion so what's a
frame of reference that is so everything
in physics if I'm if I'm moving moving
relative to what moving to relative to
the observer moving relative to the
earth you don't know so a frame of
reference is
what is the observer doing so example
when I'm in space and I let go of the
Apple me and the Apple are kind of in
this I am observing the Apple from what
I call an inertial frame of reference so
this is a frame of reference actually
where Newton's laws hold if I take the
Apple on earth and I let go and it drops
the reason why this first law didn't
hold is because I'm not really in an
inertial frame of reference because me
and the Apple are both constantly being
pulled on by this force called gravity
so although it looks like you know
nothing's going on me and the Apple
aren't the same you know where nothing's
really acting on us there is there's
this force of acceleration similarly if
I'm in a car and that car is
accelerating right so you know let's say
the car looks more like a pickup truck
so I'll go with the pickup truck so
we've all you know and you have that
little thing let's say you have a pair
of dice hanging from your rear-view
mirror right this is the dice right here
what happens when the car accelerates
well the dice move back right and so
when you're sitting in the truck itself
it looks like the dice are just moving
back no one's really doing anything to
it but the especially let's say the car
had no windows and you would just all of
a sudden mysteriously feel well you
would feel a little squeezing on your
chest too but you would also just see
these dice move back and you'd say hey
this Newton's first law doesn't hold and
what I would say well that's because
you're in a non inertial frame of
reference to someone outside of the
truck they would see oh well the truck
is moving the truck is actually
accelerating and that's why the dice
moved back so in in I guess you could
say the horizontal dimension and I'm
probably just confusing you but I want
to give you a really intuitive feel
about why this isn't so intuitive in the
horizontal direction because there are
no forces of gravity or whatever acting
in in this direction and if I'm outside
of the truck I could then I would be in
an inertial frame of reference in at
least the horizontal dimension I mean we
always have gravity pulling down on us
but from the outside of the truck I
could observe that oh you know Newton's
law holds because this this this the
frame the whole frame of reference this
this truck is actually being accelerated
so me being outside of that
I would be in an inertial frame of
reference hopefully I haven't confused
you too much the way to think about it
is an inertial frame of reference is
just a frame of reference where there's
no outside forces acting on the whole
frame of reference and a frame of
reference is just is just what what is
the observer doing what am i doing am i
moving with the object am i being
accelerated with the object or are
neither me nor the object being acted
upon and that's the way to think about
it
I will oh I already ran out of time I
only got one law done so I'll see you in
the next video